[Music]
I didn't mean to do okay hi hi okay
that's not inverse how are you hey
bitumens nice to have you here TJ hey P
steady hey Diego Rivera hey I was gonna
say hey stream ups hey bastian bastian
like in the neverending story you have
to save us Bastian you have to give her
a new name and a handyman
hey handyman so today we are going to
play more of Gregory's Horror Show
we have two more souls to steal and
Tildy and I've never gotten this far in
the game before but you have to excuse
me because I am currently getting over
the flu and my head is killing me
it's been killing me all day and I came
home to find that I've ran out of
paracetamol I might be a fine sand wall
but if I have to cut the stream short
you know why hello Miguel Ponce and Nick
egorov let's continue with the game
I might have to turn down the game
volume again because I remember the last
time there were some issues with that so
just let me know if you want me to turn
it down again but um I'm so glad I feel
better like the last few days I
literally felt like I was in another
dimension and then everyone was talking
about coronavirus and I was like no so
scary but don't worry I don't have that
I did go to the doctors I'm fine if you
do have a cold or flu and you find that
the fever is extremely high do just get
just double check because that's kind of
a
you can know well that's what my doctor
said anyway he took my took my
temperature I was like okay your
temperature is not bad so it can't be
coronaviruses like hockey Oh
anyway enough talking about that let's
play video games okay yes so let me know
if it's too loud I have a feeling it's
probably probably wobbly so I'm gonna
just turn it down a bit now I don't know
why but this was just like really loud
for some reason this house sorry
see it's so loud I think I think I think
we're okay
but let me know if you want me to put it
down a bit so the last last time we left
off we had just taken if I am not
mistaken and that rhymes I have the
clock clock masters so always a clock
master and his little little boy wasn't
it thief stop right there no this is
what I do I'm ginger see even the
characters ginger wait do you think we
did that on purpose because that the
winning this game you can play is either
a girl or a boy in that both ginger hmm
I think there's some hair color ISM
going on okay so let's have a little
little look-see we got red herb that's
always good we got some we got some good
time things so we can like go further in
time if we get bored at the time we're
in we still have a speed up to this
school we have some good stuff actually
but I don't need to yeah let's go on the
map hmm okay so we don't want to walk
outside just yet because the chef is
there this is where the game gets really
difficult because everyone wants to kill
us so if you haven't seen this game
before just letting you know once you
take the soul of someone within this
hotel they then want to kill you because
you took their soul and basically
everyone on here apart from the cat that
you see the little dog thing with a wand
the pink dog with a wand proves us
that's the next soul we need to take the
little robot man on the right with a
little pointy head and the mouse
on the bottom apart from them they all
want to kill us all of these people and
these are all of our maps we haven't
been to basement three there's the clock
master that's the soul we just took okay
so we'll wait for this one to go past
unfortunately the save room doesn't have
a peephole
so we can't look through ah no worries
Nikki thanks for dropping in any way
have a fun evening doing whatever you're
doing all day I don't know where you
live
hey Piero how'd you reckon he's gone yet
know why you walk so slow in Poland it's
a running joke that June just helps new
Souls yeah Lucas I think that's I think
that's a running joke like everywhere
cuz you know that someone like wasn't it
like gingers have souls
[Music]
oh come on wait a walk so slowly
and sew up the top left that's our
insanity meter read Harrison's stuff
will make us more sane because you know
everyone knows if you start to go insane
all you have to do is just eat some
flowers and then you feel better again
and then okay we can probably go now
right so we took the clock masters soul
and now getting used to these controls
again now we need to figure out how to
take the sorry hello
I just expect it'll be at the freaking
people as soon as like look at our
I didn't even know whose bedroom I'm
hiding in this could be really bad don't
hear that she is Miss Kim is so anxiety
do you say no she has like colorful eyes
she's not saying anything we need to get
hurt soul somehow how we do this
[Music]
oh the little careless down here and she
freaks me the hell out
I see what niphas ambe's doing will the
racket from that dog and the mouse
what mouse Oh Gregory someone should go
put a stop to it they wouldn't fight if
they just stay away from each other so
they fight when they're together maybe
it's not Gregory maybe it is
Gregory's son James so if we go down to
James and we get him to follow us which
he does do you can lead him to
hello can't see ya come on James let's
go come on then follow me
you stupid annoying brat I mean mouth
yeah
speciesist so we need to take you to a
safe route to the dog that's good
come on James this way so usually we
don't want James to follow us because he
doesn't allow us to peepholes cuz he
tells us tells us granddad we gotta get
there before they do
where is she is she in this one yeah
good she's up here okay let's see what
happens
[Music]
no I bought it I bought you a mouse
I bought you a mouse friend you wanna
you know what a mouse
no James don't get bored I want her to
fight with the mouse
[Music]
[Music]
okay that didn't work we need to spy on
more people to figure out how to how to
do this okay she's gonna come back
she's still running away
I've never seen anyone so stubborn he
took mom she took my Gregory she doesn't
care about the little mouse see I like
this cuz the mechanic is about spying on
people and getting to know them through
that way and then working out their
weaknesses and that's how you take their
souls 101 how did it take souls that
ginger has a big pup
does she I mean she's just a triangle
really uh call me a fake game but I've
never heard of this game before what is
it gregory horror show is like one of my
favorite childhood games it's on the ps2
it's a really old game but you it's
based off a Japanese TV show and you can
watch all of the series on YouTube and
it's so freakin good I love it and you
guys look really enjoying this too even
though it's such an old game which I'm
very happy about hey Maria
when the fugitive arrives at his
destination what awaits in that
I know that I shall never find out and
just knowing this makes me wary that
makes no freaking sense I didn't help me
at all come on someone around here is
gonna know something you should spy on
next round
break time
uncle Gregory was taking a break he
wasn't doing the cleaning he was reading
a book so okay so I have to wait for
Gregory to read a book this makes no
sense
well we know it's something to do with
Gregory oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
he's moving wait is he is he going maybe
it isn't the way freak down
oh [ __ ] it's code master James [ __ ] this
way
why are you doing aren't you not care
about me I'm good too thank God Oh
Catherine up there I'm not going that
way cuz it's late at night she's there
talking to you okay I need to eat
something for my sanity
yeah that really helped good glad I have
that already shoes handy
see what they're talking about
he was coming now
he's always barging into cleaning when
I'm watching football
okay and yet something sometimes he
shakes it up for cleaning it holds
himself up and those books of his oh
[ __ ] I think we're being chased nope
see if we were to say that he would have
definitely killed us oh this is going
for a jog I can't be like Gregory always
putting off cleaning just read that
fishy-looking book where are we talking
about the porno magazine that I've got
yes I have an opponent I have mouse born
here erotic night pressure that's called
alright let's sleep so why does V go
insane I think it's game over yeah I'm
pretty sure it's game over
okay now help me a little bit yes a look
if I give him this this book he goes all
crazy
watch watch this where is he
come back bye Nikki thanks for popping
in Gregory come back I've got your dirty
book what can I do I'm guarding it with
my life it's no use
so now he's gonna run to the storage but
I don't think this is very what I'm
supposed to be doing because I've
already done this with him once it's
again why did I do that
I can't move why I think I just did it
for fun maybe I have to wait till she's
in there and then do that with him do
you guys think yeah I reckon that's
probably it
see it says dirty book corner it says
dirty corner it add to me is this is
taught me what we have to do okay
damn it
but now he has the freaking book okay
why do I give him that bird I'm an idiot
I mean you don't want to go up there
okay I'm just staying here
[Music]
curtly mama do you think they'd stop if
they know if the game knows you're like
peeking at them probably I think you got
this young man I think I got it too oh
wait
Katherine came out he's listening he's
listening to people oh love hearts in
this room
and what's the dog thing isn't it
[Music]
Gregory and his books
yes it's books you passed out I'm sorry
mama Papa well and I took them as well
so we're getting hints - what's what's
gonna happen at the end of Gregory's mom
[Music]
I'm gonna go and try and get sane again
probably sleeping I think will be too
soon to do anything so you might have to
read a book or something
[Music]
don't get in my way
what just happened something oh [ __ ]
out
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
absolutely I'm gonna die but it's okay
when would at least have the book back
okay let's restart from the safe don't
kill me
I'm label and I'm ill so this is what
happens when when your meter runs out
you're trapped in Gregory House for
eternity
No Oh
thank you for subscribing PC master five
seven seven years game over
let's try again okay we know what we're
doing this time we got this I used to be
such a completionist when I was a kid I
used to like try and peek in on everyone
so I could um I could fill out my my
diary
with what everyone was doing throughout
the day and even if I died I would like
to try and peek in on them again at the
same point even though I know exactly
what they're gonna say and exactly what
they're doing because there is a little
diary I wonder if you can see it from
here actually no key items these are
Souls I've got see I only got two left I
know you can only see it in your bedroom
but yeah that was bloody see you see how
crazy this game gets so many people want
to kill you and it's just this is not
fair you just make one wrong move and
then suddenly you're running into them
everywhere at least you don't want to
kill me because you don't have a soul Oh
hurry up chef Jesus maybe I should just
save the game after chef has gone past
Thank You brush following Oh ash thank
you for following yeah maybe I'll just
resave after he's walked past coz I'm
bored of waiting every bloody time for
him to go past
they seem to walk so slowly when you
just look at the map anyway well I've
been ill I've been working on the horror
story that is still in progress
the the story is all written out that
audio is done Jamie's done an amazing
job of Prague soundtrack to that story
the audio has been recorded for it as
well and now I'm just making the scenes
in unreal we've got some there's some
animation some sprite animation I've
drawn it frame by frame in Photoshop and
I was messing around with
post-processing and it looks so freakin
cool we've got like shades in the 3d
world now so it knows where the shadows
are but instead of drawing shadows it
draws like sketches you're like in manga
like I don't know if any of you guys
know like jaunty itö but like he does
like knows a little edging in pen and it
does that for the shadows now and I'm
like I'm so happy with it but anyway
that will be coming soon ish I don't
know I keep pushing it because I just
want it to be really good and I'm
learning those four there anyway so
let's I'm guessing he's going on so we
can save the game again yes good I'm
gonna save the game here so we don't
have to wait for him to walk again
oh [ __ ]
alum I'll take some screenshots of what
what the horror story thing looks like
now before my patreon so you guys can
see it
[Music]
fat bearded boy hey okay right so we
have the way for a dog friend to be in
the room at the top right and then we
take the mouse pornos
it's a Gregory and then Gregory goes in
there and has good old time and pisses
her off I mean I can understand why
should be annoyed to be fair and lovely
luckily let's let's read a book Wow
we'll use this first so let's let's move
wait
I wonder so we have this you know in
refill much
do we find out when that when she goes
in there at least this is one we know
where they'll be
these are all the new people so now we
just know when she's having a
conversation damn it okay
well just what is use the fruit of time
so happens Oh balls
okay I see where she is now oh she's
talking with Nikko's on V again okay
well let's read a book and get us sanity
up actually let's go to sleep because
I'll move time as well what platform
you're playing this absolute classic on
it's a ps2 game but I'm playing on an
emulator but yeah it's like one of my
favorite games as a kid he's so good I
just randomly found it in game station
you know when used to just put in games
and just yep I found this one that was
like Oh a horror game but it's the
cutest horror game I've ever played oh
she's still not there what is she
supposed to be
we're just gonna sneaking around it's
just go sneaking around I like looking
at these ones as well as you can toggle
their animations that was really cool
it's a really cool idea so you can check
out everything if you want to if you
like me what you do want to see more of
see this is Gregory game is weird eyes
oh I thought we've gone how do we get
them I don't know how we get them
that's Piron on Catherine I see what
she's dreaming about who's in your
dreams
tackling voice coming from the storeroom
oh it's Gregory is Gregory when he's
reading his porn yeah we need to find
out when she's going to be in the same
room and then we can set it up oh
schizer coming out which way she go she
going this way
oh [ __ ]
nope nope nope nope nope no I think the
basement is mainly here so that you
could actually get around the first
floor okay cuz there's so many things
that want to kill you on both the first
and second floors is ridiculous but look
at the basements only one person will
also kill me down there I think Nick a
zombies going a bit crazy
because I'm in general in our Kosambi is
okay but when it gets really hungry they
will destroy you what's the truth I need
to know this was Gregory's evil mama
yeah yeah he's listening into all the
bedrooms
he is listening to all the rooms yes it
looks like this game isn't as metal as I
thought I thought the game knew when you
were spying on them and then it like
helped to you by stopping them so you
could listen to what they're talking
about
wait what Gregory where the Frick are
you extra special oh there you are
what yeah I wonder why that is
it's like someone's been taking all the
souls hi this looks scary
I hope you're having a wonderful day
hope you are too and gaming channel it's
not been bad I'm getting over the flu
but I'm so much better than you sleep
right let's just try and sleep again
yeah you need a soul to talk to death
[Music]
maybe we can read as weak judgment about
whatever it is wait let's pick up some
more books
maybe we should just go yey-hey my men
some girls got bigger yeah maybe we
should just go in like pick up loads of
supplies while we're waiting
oh did you already have this game ah Sh
I had no idea no one ever knows what
this game is and whenever I find anyone
that does I'm just like ah it makes me
so happy cuz yeah no one even knew
existed because it was the Japanese
anime that was based off of so no one
really knew that either but Capcom made
this ghetto Capcom time for me to get
back to work yes
stop spying on people I would never go
trying trying to loot some stuff
so many people what's up says okay
you know someone who's speedrun what
Gregory hoar shoe yeah you probably do
actually if you already know like what
you're doing
Green hurt
Oh red herb even better huh can you tell
it was Capcom never anything in this
room but it looks like there should be I
it hurts my eyes have already cut
headache
[Music]
[Music]
is anyone downstairs
okay
see some sucks I need to get some perks
which I was watching the football
I want to stop my team I wanna see them
score a goal this is what the dog
watches have football concentrate you
have to keep studying daddy said that if
I don't study hard I'll end up by Yaga
lag rude the true
when is she actually gonna be doing
things I'm gonna say it again
first time I saw many Oh games within
our rink on DiGiorgio yeah I need to
make more games I actually have an idea
for a little one I want to make games on
social commentary I'm actually so
excited about this who I want him to
send dyed-in-the-wool enemies Ninja
Theory did you guys see their trailer
for like the game that they're making
and also how Blade 2 looks so good I
like that they're getting psychologists
involved as well to do it right
it's so irritating that we just have to
wait for this one moment
can I sleep yeah what a horrible
nightmare every morning where is she
paceman she is bloody annoying she's
like never where I wanted to be alright
Walt Ryan use the gold on the stopwatch
for them where outwards time stuff oh we
can use it again this is perfect
alright alright she might move at 12 oz
fees or just who's in the library I was
honey Gregory okay cool
we're in the library and collectable
books because Gregory want her ass he's
the guy who owns the hotel see it's Rob
so everyone's gonna start on their
different routes wait that means someone
might come to the library okay well
hurry well hurry up
anything here there's only one book in
the library when someone's hungry it's
best to feed him he'll surely remember
the kindness showed him today's proverb
one good turn deserves another maybe we
should feed never zombie then I wonder I
wonder if it's hungry where's to get
that banana from oh yes I remember
can we go get it now yeah should be free
should be super clear
hey what's like cutest duck I'm paying
your favorite game sweets it's always so
nice of people know this game is such a
nice little game thank you for
subscribing Alex what's that Alex
villain new and faster
[Music]
[Music]
it's a 1 in here yeah okay
let's go pick up some weed let's go play
with some plants oh my god guys this
valentine's day tomorrow
[Music]
I was a tasked with a buying my
housemates partners and flowers today
thank you really you trust me to get the
flowers that you're ready to go
she gave me some specific advice
colorful and summery so I got like
multicolored tulips I hope that was good
what's in the souls thank god I hate it
hey when you hear the door noise okay
I'm just going I'm going hey Matt Reeves
this is an emulator version yes I am NOT
streaming through the PlayStation I
don't have a capture card I'm going to
save I feel like wearing pretty good dog
[Music]
are you hungry
dang it why would she be watching
football in that room this doesn't make
any sense yeah sure I have this banana
[Music]
[Music]
alright I'm gonna use this again oh I
hope you get to use it unlimited times
ah do you think we do what do you think
there's an amount that we can use it
would be very cool if we could use it
multiple times I don't know why I keep
going off it to go back on it yeah I
wouldn't be in a bedroom the only place
that he goes when he has the book is in
the storage room when he we need to we
need to go and spy on some more people
to me
still having flashbacks at the clock and
the Sun yeah I know that was so annoying
I literally am I was on lunch today with
my friend Brayden and I explained to him
exactly how I got that soul because it
was so detailed like everything that you
had to do and he was like feel like I
went on it early so yeah it was
difficult but we did it guys I'm so
proud of
[Music]
well was that cutest duck said that
you're gonna not going to be a backseat
gamer so I'm guessing I've got the wrong
idea of like what's supposed to happen
here it makes no sense cuz that's the
only place that he goes for the first
cars of what here
stingy with downstairs we good thank you
for following Frank Frank first if you
want souls that bad why don't you get
something wrong there's always those
souls wandering in to this place okay
you told my gregory's mom I don't care
about that right now I need to find out
about the dog oh my god controls can i
peek through corners this way so I could
kisses spooky
I'll fight them all over the place
damn girl hey Montez welcome Hey
I hope work was fun good either way
visit evil - we make looking good wait
what
I can't wait for wasn't even three we
make stars Wow girls although I don't
know I'm not a massive fan of the way
that he speaks hopefully he'll speak
better in the game because I I don't
even notice that he's like said stars
and then my friend was like no watch it
again at the end it's kind of like a
it's like a real you can hardly tell
unless you you're listening for it are
you doing angel dog yes
I'm doing angel dog angel dog is my last
one of doing angel dog and I know it's
something to do with the porno magazine
that I've got I think I have to wait for
angel dog to go into the room that
Gregory runs into which is the storeroom
once he gets the porn thing but she's
watching football though right and wow
oh sorry I've got hiccups why would she
be watching football in the storeroom
that makes no sense
maybe I can put the dirty magazine in
the lounge
cuz surely that's why she would be
watching the football right
right right I'm gonna try and put it in
the lounge
and I need to eat something busy day but
generally quite good sloppy yeah hell
yeah I know how much that sucks
I hate when I've made a new mechanic and
I have to set up the playtest
getting room to play it and have them
all say everything that's wrong with it
but you need feedback so you know it's
good it's good and use their they're
really nice about it can I go this way
is anything gonna kill me here no good
don't you bloody dare okay good okay
what are we where do I leave where do I
leave this can I leave this anywhere
clearly this year did I leave it here
can I leave it here I don't leave this
magazine anyway oh I got a new book can
I leave it over here can I leave this
here leave this there [ __ ]
it was a deal I know he wants to jump oh
[ __ ]
hi this is the time this is the moment
what do we do my maid she's gonna watch
her show though but I need my book
though maybe I give it to him and then
maybe for some weird reason he comes in
here and said of the story
I'm not here I'm not here I'm a curtain
I'm a ginger curtain skills [ __ ]
mmm [ __ ] and Catherine's out where's she
going oh she's not is she out
I see how annoying sneaky sneaky sneaky
snake
[Music]
now you wouldn't be able to trap her in
the room because they forcibly push you
aside so they can go out the door
good good idea though okay
[Music]
you can give the book to Gregory he
better not go to the storeroom there
that's all I'm saying that's what he's
been doing the whole entire time cuz I
found out this like at the very
beginning of the game I remember finding
out for the first time when I was a kid
and I had no idea what was going on I
was like wait why is this sexy mice oh
thanks talking to the freakin chef how
do I get the shaft leave I'm so annoying
there's daily people about at least I
know what time was and what time is it
now
five
Falkor past five right
may I leave please
[Music]
aha stop he's pacing the hole hit can't
leave this game help me in a lot of ways
when I was younger what do you mean in
what ways I'm intrigued tell the church
hello chat if you want to you know after
it's too personal I've been thinking
guys about doing I might have talked to
this last time actually and thinking
about doing a video on animal crossing
just because they helped me in so many
ways and I was a kid so I'm looking to
fillers and I've seen like a lot of
people do heartfelt videos on animal
crossing I was like oh I have
experiences - maybe I should share them
so if you'd like to see a video on
animal crossing let me know I might just
make one anyway
I'm so I'm so excited for the new game
oh I'm kickin butt quoting in stories it
gave me an imagination either so true it
did the same for me actually I used to
write stories about this as well like
this whole limbo esque concept and the
characters I loved the character
creation in this game the characters are
so well fleshed out dude how am I
supposed to get to Gregory it's actually
behind me
he's got bodyguards everywhere we'll
talk about so much but I know what I'm
saying but have no pity gave myself I
don't really know what kind of game is
okay this this this settles it oh you
must making Animal Crossing video I'm
asked I'm asked I know where Gregory is
but look he'll chef is right there and
he's gonna kill me he's gonna kill me Oh
Shay it's not there anymore no [ __ ] off
stupid controls
why is my mouse there sudden
wait wait oh but Catherine's gonna get
me us too
I'm gonna speed up speedy speedy let's
go [ __ ] controls the only thing with
kitten fixed camera angles Catherine
[ __ ] off
[ __ ] little [ __ ] just wait for Catherine
to go Gregor gonna have your book I have
your sexy book no no I'm not even I'm
just going back to my last save
[Music]
because they're not gonna be in there
anymore
yeah see now that's a lizard who loves
blood so much so that she basically lets
live the game from my last save
a mud lad right from work Ritchie you
should be working what Elsa thank you
wait what oh I think she's going in
there now right
8:8 any thing but I'm gonna get trapped
in him
you
here we go whereas Gregory [ __ ] [ __ ]
ducks
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
rehabs in here okay cool so do we still
just have to wait for what for Catherine
to go and then for him to pace the
hallway and then for chef to go then we
can go and say hi to Gregory this is
getting too much now really
think I need a new charger you got
exposed wires
hey deaf 1 5 7 and hey Alex I don't know
if I said hi yet hi hi hey arty
okay we can go I think let's get out
there
still that ever I think he won't be
there for long
please
please leave I don't even know how he
laughed he just wasn't there one minute
why do they set it up like this ah and
now he's leaving
ah
Oh [ __ ] sake Catherine get help okay
so he's going in there she's going in
there so ready I'm so ready I'm so ready
so ready I'm so ready look at me I'm so
pretty yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes come on we're not dying
today not today yes okay
so do I just do IP rim fresh so I give
him the book like what do I do
[ __ ] I'm going in Gregory you have
your sexy back wait what
how annoying boy
well how what what what okay cool
they're arguing but now what hello yo
annoying boy Gregory I have your book
mate mate try all the books I don't know
oh dude what am I supposed to do now
no that's absolutely ridiculous oh I
have to give him the book before he
argues with a dog he's talking to
freaking chef the whole entire time
[Music]
hmm just start the roaming books with
them
I'm giving them all the books I got I'm
just gonna spy on them so at least I
know what time now we're just gonna I'm
gonna use the our little time thing
ling-ling you're in the way get out this
instant why don't you forget about
cleaning taking a nap or something I'll
clean this room if it's the last thing I
do
maybe maybe I just have to watch them
fight what do you prefer to fix of yours
you cheeky mongrel you shouldn't be
talking
you're nothing but a fella tower at
yourself
what
oh I'm just really going here [ __ ] this
is so annoying
TV TV remote I agree honestly how
annoying
right I'm gonna try we're gonna try we
were trying go to our room without being
killed and then we'll sleep for a bit
and then we'll just use the time magicky
stuff - no no I'm not reading that I'm
not reading it I'm not reading it I want
to frighten this out I think what I'm
going to do [ __ ] what I'm going to do is
I'm going to
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
yeah I'm safe ah yeah what am I gonna
say I'm gonna get asleep I'm gonna try
and make the time go around again 24
hours and then he'll shut wicked chef go
and then hopefully I don't know
hopefully he'll chef won't be talking to
Gregory this time and we can actually
give him the book before he goes into
the lounge I don't know I thought you
had to plant the book in the lounge or
something I'm not too sure
I made clothes I kind of want to cheat
but I don't I'm not I don't want to look
at this comment because I don't want to
cheat dude Catherine chase pastor
what time is it okay
thank you for following up Audrey Frost
Oh
well at least we've seen when it's going
to happen
wait this is the morning time than that
yeah here we go back to Caesar
[Music]
so got a long way to go what are those
two doing in the library maybe we're
going direct grant get some green herbs
as well
Brown the meat into its crumbly Oh game
can't handle too many characters in one
room
[Music]
anyone catches gunman's in there I can't
go in there okay I'll just go back to my
room
Carrie I'm waiting I guess and then we
will read it back I think that for its
time as well why did he name my son cuz
he's a son of the clock master wait I
don't know why we've got this red
hankerchief either I'm guessing we might
need it like the end
I look at all the books or themed like
the characters as well
woohoo did that even update the time oh
yeah yeah raising 100 hey no one's in
where the green perhaps I'm every can go
grab some
I'm so glad we picked up this watch it's
making this game so much faster I'd hate
to have waited a full 24 hours
can't combine them though Oh what's this
shiny yeah we'd cook him yeah of course
you would of course you would I think I
can do more spying seems pretty pretty
chill down here
are you off Nikki by Nikki
thanks for coming again they have a
medkit I could take
Oh
six
oh maybe what I have to do around 6:00
oh my god guys I think I've got it
I think I just need to let her watch the
football I think I need to give oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
I think I need to him and he's give
Gregory the book around 6 so that he's
preoccupied reading his filthy book so
she can actually watch the football and
then she'll be too into the football to
notice that I'm taking I solo my god I'm
a genius that is it isn't it that is
actually yeah I'm a genius why is my
mouse here right now we just need the
time to come and I need to pop the
toilet
IRL there are no Twitter's in this hotel
oh it's almost time
whoo exciting okay
Oh tell you what should we save the game
and then I go toilet
I feel like we've gotten somewhere meant
what's up scoffing in that time sounds
good coffee break everyone Katherine's
going to bed so we may go out into the
hallway save the game and then I'm gonna
go to the toilet and you guys can all
have a little break ribbit cool I will
see you guys shortly I'll put this on a
little BRB screen see Anna beat
alright I'm back let's do this
did I save pretty sure I save didn't I'm
pretty sure I saved
that gamma check welcome back thank you
there were no legit links on the brake
spring were there any links on my breaks
free oh no they're just pictures they're
not actual links you can click on [ __ ]
we're stuck in the same dilemma
oh no we're stuck in the same dilemma we
need to like mmm it's ok it's ok I think
I know what these thing
I think I knew oh we need a wheeze hide
what's my day job I'm a game designer
which I've been training pool for like
six years
oh [ __ ] I need to go that way and
they're all that way and then I go down
this way up the stairs
yes that is what I was
this is so exert inducing
[ __ ] off yellow [ __ ] oh you're so
annoying
ain't you what things
is he gonna come
seem to wait till it's a bit safe maybe
I'll save the game here hold up hold up
[Music]
if this
[Music]
[Music]
when you were changing the saying oh
it's just like feedback in it so you
know that your your button clicks are
doing the thing yes perfect to perfect
my paralyzed we caveman them today I won
the brunette game but the prize was just
some stupid old book I didn't want that
so I got a big hunk of blood in me and
said hmm should I give this to
I'm excited thinking about it oh I
should give it it's allowance day time
to get paid but now that I think of it
must be pretty tough for grandpa to keep
this place and running all the time
especially that old wrinkled hag around
manche gives me the creeps
okay now I can just thank you for
subscribing mowing as sucka
well they say it especially that moody
dog TV at home two hours
you know my characters know the hi his
mom is the hag come on Craig wait
come on Gregor wait I don't want to
prematurely what am i doing that's
landed Gregory
look at me look at me I'm here agon be
wise now yes who doesn't go into the
lounge so what does that mean for me
does that mean they're like
I can go in here and she'll just give it
to me because I've like I've done this
for her
maybe
project Silva so let's go okay I [ __ ]
it come back please come back please I
don't know what to do then maybe I just
have to wait until the end of the match
or something
she's gonna come back
Wow if she does
she's coming back
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you no [ __ ]
[Music]
I'm being chased now like in my way
[Music]
please fall maybe stupid dog [ __ ]
[ __ ] both can't be after this [ __ ] I'm
loading my thing this is so annoying
wait we know what we're doing don't
laugh when we're on to us don't laugh at
me you were our man
[Music]
I didn't hear you call this we got this
we got this we got this
I saw that's the feed bad thing so I
probably didn't explain that what
feedback is just some a design term for
letting the user know that their input
was valid and had done something so
giving them feedback on what they did
would be wise not to me honey dealing
how babies get away from James we need
to get away from James so tonight so I
only say that cuz if James follows us we
can't peep like he's very annoying it's
very good it's like an annoying little
brother unless you're a little brother
I'm sure you need one
I probably shouldn't stay on this card
although should I it's gonna end up
coming I don't know in what room he goes
I hope it's not this one medikit oh yeah
please don't say that
bloody dog is coming in here what is
that other one I mean this is the dog
what's the other thing
I think you will passed it thank God
Mersey please [ __ ] off
yeah but they have stop fighting he's
not even in there and he wants to stop
your whining
[Music]
yeah that's very funny that you were
able to find the book before this like I
guess chapter of the game because
usually they'll give you the items as
you need them I had this one ages a guy
so yeah yeah just something interesting
but it's nice it's a it's a nice little
callback it makes the player feel like
really good about themselves like I
already figured this out ages go oh it's
not I thought that was one of those mind
blots you know where it was like one of
those things was like what do you see in
in the mind Bloods in the mind in the
ink blots ink blots that's what I meant
who's going who's going
oh now for the next one
haven't seen him know who that gorgeous
floating guy
what TV fish I wonder when he's coming
I'll have to ask judgment boy that's
true actually where is TV fish oh there
is ok ok let's go give death our song
come on now
give it up the way old am worried the
only want me one huh
this dude is in the Gold Room exciting
that was refreshing oh okay let's go
let's go visit mr. gold judgment boy and
then I'll probably leave after this
where is he
you see you then know what what's the
protocol is hmm
and so people have to say about it
oh you've gone crazy I want to go this
hotel - okay yeah I mean good advice but
nothing I didn't know is he he's not
you're a liar
he's not my map and this is on the very
bottom basement floor okay if we're
going to the basement I'm saving my game
we got more little toys for our bedroom
[Music]
seriously chicky up dress on Katherine
see I can't ever seem to spy on people
from this door which is ridiculous which
you can see them annoying okay just like
the too far away now but I can still see
them Oh broken bug
clock moment oh [ __ ] cactus cactus cook
just gone mine I should be going to the
basement really should mine
you just give in and that mama do what
she wants
there's be no need for the suffering
just let yourself be transformed into a
delicious let's see I haven't seen this
girl
where's she going
oh yes there yes we found him
it's in the room
he's in his golden raisin
one of my games one of his games one of
what games who is playing what game no
I'm talking I'm talking to you Alex
what's theirs lazy pupils of mine it's
obvious they haven't been training
themselves are you talking about the
other judgement boys yeah Galax got more
guts than they'll ever have the kid
ought to stay and become my pupil
instead of going back to reality
no I want reality but anyway let's let's
check hey your amazing skills have
gotten you this far okay do it guys
[Music]
gunman trying to steal okay watching TV
in the conference room so what is he
watching look like you are testing me on
how well I know the characters damn it
if I was a kid I would know all these
answers oh well this is pretty easy
maybe that's a trick question
that's a good thing I haven't known
Catherine dated at the bar I know I hate
who do we think guys here's who is
Catherine dating I reckon this house
chef I would go for House chef I just I
just don't think gargery's got that mmm
you know and also Gregory is the boss
all right food is king
duh okay I actually didn't even realize
Catherine's going on dates around the
hotel shows that I'm living a fan yes
you got it right we got it right we got
it right we got it right right this is
an angel dog no that's so obvious game
why are you so easy oh yeah you're made
for kids
[Music]
money or love only the scales no she's
watching her like love dating romance
faces she oh I don't know what she's
eating poor Fork
ah what's she eating Oh ritzy
fifty-fifty I don't know a snack cake is
it's probably us I don't know what you
think Leon says donor I'm gonna wait for
you guys I don't know ah so say Donen
shadow donut yeah no one else is saying
anything so I'm gonna go for it don't go
for a donut donut I'm paying putting
this one on you Leon
oh yeah you did it three nice one
thank you this is it this is his final
round always goes to a certain place at
8:00 in the morning
this is hot
ah he goes to the nurses room Allah
please get it right please he's got an
axe in his head but this could be a
trick question I like that a game
actually put you spying on the people
and getting to know them as like one of
the main challenges at the end I really
like that
looks like you've still got the mental
fortitude to face reality and enjoy the
trails ahead of you as a symbol of your
will to overcome the difficult tests
that await you I'll give you a fabulous
prize mat so thank you all a hands as
well no no no no that's not true that's
not true okay
I actually trying to pick up your soul
whatever pick up the bloody soul
yeah yeah oh no no so so with um
judgment boys money kind of means fake
materialistic heart is like real love
you know so basically heart means right
money means wrong
so whenever the money drops you know
you've got everything right because the
heart is so intact
that's what that means yeah okay
and why did I eat why did I waste that
Oh times Wow Hisle icon it's so weird
just like a yellow blob we're gonna find
a way back down now without being cute
yeah
oh we progressed very much very proud of
us oh nice I'm just happy
I love games right okay
here's our ad how am i doing I'm much
better I feel much better after the flu
I always feel bad in the mornings
mornings the worst time for me but yeah
the flu is definitely pretty much gone
now okay time to you gotta go save my
game and then give my soul actually no I
just give my soul I'm a chronic saver
you never know what's gonna happen you
know
[Music]
Oh give it up
so you only one huh
[Music]
sorry I'm just I tried to complete this
game so much when I was a kid and this
is like really nostalgic what do you
mean
see I'm nice I release the souls the
answers talked in echoes um be first
before his Academy bravery is it really
true is that brat
actually collecting souls yes it's true
mama the child the child has already
freed all of them this was all your
fault
can't you remember anything at all
this is the last straw I'm going to
drink that kid so
okay don't think this is quite the end
wait do we have a new new toys yeah we
have characters Garman where's your pew
pew you can peeping me
do we submitted the council oh my god
wait was this because I released the
more so now they're evolving release
that's great well I'm gonna save the
game chronic saver
[Music]
[Music]
okay we're gonna say hi to Nick a zombie
mm-hmm
Kisame come with me I really wait
what's her voice I really didn't like
think you would ever get this far I
thought you'd be like everyone else
who's come so far you'd get tired of
fighting try to escape get lost and end
up becoming a prominent guest in the
hotel but you were different
only you truly had the will to return to
reality yes and only you worked so hard
to achieve your goal anybody can make a
wish
but how can actually make how many can
actually make it come true thank you
I've made a decision of my own right
then all you have to do is go out the
front door in the lobby
once you're through that door promise me
you'll keep going and never look back
oh you're so cute II oh no I don't want
okay cool bye it's good wait wait do I
have anything in here that I might need
on it I don't feel like I'm prepared for
this
just in case I need mics what was that
vet hankichi for I have not a clue
[Music]
do this wat sake
get away
no don't hit me oh thank you she made a
crack in the door okay so do we have to
like get her to hit the door punch time
so that opens probably they made it
pretty obvious gave up on me now
keep heading for the exit okay well I'm
in alright it's not it's not thrown okay
cool
[Music]
good I still have all my stuff
I don't know where I'm going
I'm sure I'll find my way though can't
be that hard
there we go [ __ ] okay okay I mean of
course
hey Piero and Alex and I'll Kissin we're
so close to the end of this game this is
all entirely new for me Oh
ah this is where we saw in the in the
cutscene with Gregory talking to his mom
so I guess we're gonna confront her
one-on-one cool ok boss bow
[Music]
oh this so much stuff okay let's drop
this
do I need my hanky do I need the hanky I
don't think I need this anymore I'm
gonna drop it wait [ __ ]
[Music]
go let's go scour while we can
Oh
Yeah right which means I just come from
oK we've got a little soundtrack of hope
so uh it's making me feel good this is
the way up
the game again oh [ __ ] no no wait yeah
[Music]
okay cool I'm fast I'm speedy I'm speedy
speedy with me
[ __ ] I went to like here because
obviously video game logic but you know
oh ok so that I get it now I get it I
get it
the ball no no
I'll [ __ ] [ __ ] it
no but you can't oh you're on the wrong
[ __ ] way meet John no [ __ ] way
this way
okay okay hey me hear me [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh no not actually me this is ready
hansika has an aim at the [ __ ] door
no no no no that's never gonna work
she's too close to the door
oh god that's my last no that's not
gonna work you need to stay away from
the bloody door to leave
oh they away from the [ __ ] door okay
yes okay oh we just need your patient
guys we just need to be patient I like
this pillow come get me yes this is so
stupid
[Music]
do you fire Pumas
yes Oh hangry okay here we go oh no I'm
an idiot I'm an eejit okay it's okay
I've got my angel face [ __ ]
Oh God trap me Oh
oh Jesus she's gone crazy crazy crazy
crazy
[Music]
[Laughter]
we do a command you'll see I'll come
back right Oh Michael angel angel yeah
yes yes oh my god they hit make it oh
please say that's it because I have
nothing left no far from my hangar cheek
is that Gregory's soul what dark night
did I do something like bad in my life
and that's why I've left no mousey ghost
no I will not
oh dude so if I laugh and I didn't have
much insanity but I not make it through
this or because that would be harsh if I
just made it with a little bit sanity
left and then I don't make that the 6th
night
gotta say I'm impressed
I can't promise I'll send you back
follow this
thank you for following Alonso I don't I
came back to come with you can't these
shackles they're my burden you know I
can't bring myself to forget my pain
the handkerchief
I don't need your teddy
just go you've already made your choice
why wouldn't you let me help you
don't you worry about a thing mama I'll
go catch the little rascal in no time at
all you can count on me what are you
doing here
get back in your room
yes settle umpire that time
no I lost all his love in it Oh
by Gregory
is a reflection
my
my hand kerchief No
[Music]
I heard a screen behind me turning
around I saw flame Helen flames
crumbling to the ground how I got myself
into this mess I will never know all I
could do was run run away along that
path
[Music]
now at last I understand the hotel was
my own creation the way to escape from
you at all I had escaped from the hotel
[Music]
[Music]
was to face a cold empty future full of
suffering but if I ever become tired of
my struggle with reality
I know I'll find my way back to the
hotel again
when that time comes I might never
return to the room it's so meta
oh no such a good game such a game oh so
many things I love about that game oh so
good
I wish they would remake it or make
another one just so good I just I love
the fact that it's about getting to know
characters characters that have written
wait there's more
it's being rebuilt ready for the next
time all comes back full circle guys and
so begins another
it starts again I knew you'd be coming
back eventually everyone comes back to
Gregory house
rest
I love that is that the mo yes say baby
baby back does that mean if I play again
it will be something different
pretty sure yeah
oh well thank you everyone for watching
me play oh it's got a different Start
screen um I need to go really but it's
cool
I got new things all right this is
control types yeah anyway I'm gonna go
now thank you so much for joining me on
that journey of revisiting one of my
favorite childhood games I love that
game because it's just so unique
I feel the emphasis on getting to know
the characters and their daily routines
are very in your little memo book and
how it's just be aware of where all the
characters are and not only that but
every character being so unique is so
specific to each way that you can get
their souls and they're also fleshed out
as characters and they're so weird and
quirky and creepy but in a really cute
way they've really got the kind of
goosebumps vibes yes I just freaking
love it
health roulette is you get to redo your
roulette game with Hellboy which is what
Hellboy is not called Hellboy is he I
think he's got roulette boy which is
what you had to do to get his soul but
yeah it was great and I would love to
play more childhood games with you I
just need to find them for the emulator
but it's been a great ride anyway I will
definitely stream more next week make
sure that you're following me on Twitter
so you can have your say what I will
play cuz knowing me I will probably do a
poll for it and as always feel free to
join the discord and chat to us
[Music]
let me just it always has the default of
expiring DD so feel free to join the
distillate anyway I'm gonna say goodbye
to who I can see so have a lovely day or
evening and goodbye
mantas goodbye hey Kelly goodbye Lee
Anne what apparently there was a date
gained that's supposed to be released
after this called mystery holiday I
never heard of that one
why did not get released I've been
thinking like I would love to make a
game like this because to do the 3d
models and stuff wouldn't be there
difficult either because they're so low
poly
but they're anyway one can dream goodbye
Benjamin McFadden goodbye hey Kelly
goodbye Arshad zero seven who else is
here goodbye you Tara man goodbye Nikki
Gaurav was nice not watching right why
weren't you watching were you just
listening I don't know I don't know
goodbye Alex and I'll kiss and super and
good bye
anyone that haven't seen or anyone that
is watching but it's not in the chat I
still appreciate you very much and I
will see you next week so Oh bye deaf